[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings over the
past two years we've done a series of
stories on wealth in america including
the role of race the typical black
family has only a fraction of the wealth
of the typical white family and many
experts say that the root of that
problem is real estate in an earlier
story that brought me back to the county
where my grandfather bought a house way
back in 1953 an investment by the way
that has skyrocketed in value well this
morning we are sharing another
experience that of a black family that
had been hoping to make a similar
purchase in the very same county
and what happened next
and that's the end of a fairly busy day
on the new york stock exchange
1964 was a record-breaking boom year for
the u.s economy and cbs followed along
as one young couple tried to buy their
piece of it his name is corbett rochelle
since last july he and his wife sally
have visited many real estate offices
like this one the rochelle's knew
exactly what they wanted a four bedroom
home in bergen county new jersey one of
new york city's most desirable suburbs
and as it happens the very same place
where my grandfather had found a home
just a decade earlier the rochelle
search began in the usual way with the
local newspaper but as corbett and sally
visited real estate offices and asked to
see properties they ran into a problem
my grandfather did not
[Music]
as cbs documented in this rare hidden
camera footage the rochelle's were
repeatedly turned away what do you have
that you can show me today nothing in
this price range nothing at all and in
case there was any doubt about the exact
nature of this problem cbs cameras also
documented what happened when white home
buyers were sent in to ask about the
very same properties
what the rochelle's experienced was a
practice known as steering a way of
excluding black buyers from white
neighborhoods prior to the fair housing
act of 1968 it wasn't only common but
legal and very often life-changing so to
find out what happened to the rochelle's
and how it compared to the experience of
families like my own we tracked down
corbett and sally's only child alicia
only 11 at the time and asked her to
re-watch that original report
it wasn't always easy i've wondered
often as i've gone from one real estate
agency to the other
if
people realize the
[Music]
many embarrassing situations and
questions that
you have to go through
as a negro sometimes even
humiliating do you recognize
that expression on your father's face
yeah let's discuss
yeah
did he ever find the house
no
we moved out of uh new jersey
your family spent at least six months
and up to several years yeah with plenty
of money
looking to buy a home in bergen county
new jersey
and never did no
no he sure didn't
what that means is the rochelle's missed
out on one of the biggest real estate
booms in the country home prices in
bergen county have jumped as much as
six-fold even after correcting for
inflation
for families like mine who were able to
make the investment that money has
helped pay for everything from my
grandparents retirement to florida to
the travel i did as a college student
for alicia and her own three kids that
kind of generational cushion
just was not available
there wasn't a whole lot planned for
them
they had no insurance
it was yeah did you say your parents
died with no money
no money no money mm-hmm wow
and it's really sad but you know
it is what it is
what do you do with the fact that
this house that they could not buy in
bergen county
is almost definitely
worth three quarters of a million or
even a million dollars today
and your family doesn't have it because
of nothing more than racism yeah
well there's a lot of things that we
haven't had because of racism yeah the
house is just a very small part of it
that's a lot of money though it may be
but you know
money's not everything so when you think
of this whole story
and you think of your folks here
who had all the money they needed
to buy a home in one of the hottest
housing markets in the country and were
denied
only because of the color of their skin
what kind of story is this
i don't know it's the story of our
country
all right alicia it is i mean you know
people always say well that was then and
this is now but you're still paying for
that that was then
that's what's so frustrating about this
and i can only imagine
what it must have been like for her to
see her father talking about being
humiliated and being embarrassed yeah
because you're still paying the price
people sometimes say that that stuff is
ancient history yeah we just need to be
fair today and move on yeah it's not
ancient history when you can see the
living descendants of those people who
have less today because they were denied
then first let me say well done um i
remember being a rookie 2003 and one of
my mentors said don't waste your money
on things that are going to depreciate
don't buy that car it's going to lose
value that fancy watch yeah don't don't
waste your money on these material items
buy property property buy land because
one
our people worked on these lands and two
for a long time we couldn't buy property
right and these are examples of that i
should point out that alicia's family
was eventually able to buy property in
florida
and i don't know what would have
happened if they'd been able to stay in
new jersey but i do know that they were
denied their first choice for the
american dream and the consequences are
multi-generational and the reason i've
done this story and the earlier one
about my grandparents in bergen county
is because i think the question that
confronts us as a country is
this happened recently we're still
dealing with it what are we going to do
about it spot on